das ist wirklich ein bisschen paradox
professor kommunen wasser von der
harvard university meint dass unser
universum vielleicht gar nicht
existieren könnte und wasser einer der
führenden vertreter der stringtheorie
meint mit diesem ansatz indizien für die
theorie finden zu können
das wäre der absolute durchbruch und
würde unser verständnis von raum und
zeit und sechs bis sieben weiteren
dimensionen grundlegend verändern
what klicks und science fiction herzlich
willkommen würden belege für die
stringtheorie gefunden werden dann käme
das einer kompletten änderung unseres
weltbildes gleichen diese unbewiesene
hypothese besagt dass nicht teilchen die
kleinsten einheiten in unserem universum
sind sondern strings viel kleinere fäden
die je nachdem wie sie schwingen
unterschiedliche teilchen erscheinen
lassen quax personen oder laptop als
forschungsteams diese fäden allerdings
berichteten stießen sie auf etwas
unglaubliches dieses existieren nicht in
raum und zeit sondern ihn vielmehr
dimensionen nämlich 10 bis 11 aber wo
sind diese dimension warum können wir
sie nicht erfahren
auch darauf hat diese hypothese eine
antwort sie sind auf kleinstem raum
zusammengefaltet quasi zusammengeknüllt
dann durchreichen stellten die forscher
und forscherinnen dann fest dass auf
dieser grundlage aber und aber universen
existieren könnten und an diesem punkt
hat sich kommunen wasser jetzt
festgebissen zahlreiche dieser universen
können nämlich gar nicht existieren und
unser universum gehört dazu
jedenfalls so wie wir es bisher
beschrieben haben
in einem existierenden universum muss zb
die gravitation viel schwächer sein als
alle anderen kräfte das stimmt hier
gravitationswellen als folge sind nur
sehr schwach und kaum zu finden aber
eines funktioniert laut seinen
berechnungen nicht ein universum mit 70
prozent dunkler energie wie wir es hier
annehmen ein solches universum ist laut
bafa unmöglich dunkle energie ist eine
auch erst theoretisch vorhergesagt der
energie die dafür verantwortlich ist
dass unser universum immer schneller
auseinander driftet werden wir heute
noch ganz viele nachbargalaxien sehen
können wird das in ferner zukunft nicht
mehr der fall sein
sie sind zu weit weg um sie sehen zu
können 70 prozent dessen was existiert
soll diese
in unserem universum sein doch wasser
hat etwas anderes berechnet und das
widerspricht wirklich so einigen laut
seinen berechnungen für ein
existierendes universum auf basis der
stringtheorie darf diese energie keinen
festen wert haben sondern sie muss sich
verändern sprich in einem aus unserer
sicht geschlossenen systemen in unserem
universum verändert sich sehr der inhalt
das ist verrückt verrückt ist für die
physik aber auch der wert der dunklen
energie nach berechnungen wäre es viel
natürlicher wenn die dunkle energie
na ja ungefähr 1000 mal stärker wäre als
sie ist aber als natürlich wurde bisher
auch angesehen dass sie einen laut
wasser unmöglichen festen wert hätte
also schwamm drüber
da scheint einiges nicht zustimmen und
da könnte wasser jetzt helfen er hat
nämlich ausgerechnet wie sich die dunkle
energie ändern müsste wenn die
stringtheorie gelten würde und das ist
extrem langsam aber messbar
sprich wenn eine veränderung der dunklen
energie gemessen würde dann wäre das ein
starkes indiz dafür dass die
stringtheorie tatsächlich gilt das würde
wirklich alles auf den kopf stellen am
cern müsste dringend ein viel größerer
teilchenbeschleuniger gebaut werden um
die strings zu finden und wir würden in
einem doch sehr seltsamen zehn bis elf
dimensionalen universum leben im rahmen
des dark energy service wird gerade eine
dreidimensionale karte der dunklen
energie angefertigt zusätzlich werden
sich die weltraumteleskope wie first und
glied in zukunft die dunkle energie
genauer anschauen die ergebnisse könnten
wirklich revolutionär sein wenn ihr kein
video dazu und zu allen anderen themen
verpassen wollt dann abonniert clixoom
genau glocke nicht vergessen dafür hier
klicken volkmer auf whatsapp da gibt es
die videos früher dafür hier klicken
keine werbung mehr auf gigs um gibt es
wenn ihr mitglied wertet der link ist
unter dem video wer nicht mal am
computer anschauen
und hier geht es weiter mit das ende des
universums bis dann bleibt dran